guarda
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no no
[Musica]
ogni volta che accendo
vediamo un telegiornale con cadenza
regolare veniamo raggiunti da una
qualche brutta notizia delle volte è una
guerra scoppiata in un paese lontano
altre volte è una tragedia in qualche
sperduto borgo italiano un aereo che
cade una nave che affonda insomma chi
più ne ha più ne metta ma ciò che
accomuna tutte queste realtà solitamente
è la nostra reazione che brutto a dirsi
ma il più delle volte si concentra in 10
20 secondi di shock momentaneo che poi
diventano completa indifferenza nel
tempo che serve a passare alle notizie
sullo sport è così invece riceverà un
messaggio che ci informa di un caro
amico che ha avuto un incidente e lotta
tra la vita e la morte
la nostra vita cambia completamente
all'improvviso tutte le nostre energie
mentali sono rivolte a quella situazione
lì ci pensiamo giorno e notte e facciamo
tutto ciò che è in nostro potere per
aiutare per risolvere quel tipo di
situazione che ci crea così tanta
sofferenza ora questa discrepanza tra
ciò che ci sta vicino e ciò che ci sta
lontano può essere vista come una forma
di ipocrisia o di egoismo ma la realtà
che è la cosa più normale del mondo
poiché per l'essere umano è realmente
impossibile riuscire a stabilire una
reale e profonda connessione emotiva con
una realtà con cui non ha alcun tipo di
relazione personale con cui non ha
stabilito una reale connessione
individuale ecco con l'ambiente succede
esattamente la stessa cosa cioè noi
periodicamente sentiamo al telegiornale
di uragani in sicilia incendi in turchia
a 50 gradi ad agosto in canada incendi
in siberia e puntualmente non facciamo
niente che possa in qualche modo
contribuire a risolvere quel tipo di
realtà perché abbiamo perso
completamente il contatto personale con
l'ambiente che ci circonda
già solo la generazione dei miei nonni
questa relazione ce l'aveva eccome
perché mia nonna sa perfettamente che
per ottenere qualcosa dell'ambiente
prima gli devi dare qualcosa mentre noi
siamo cresciuti in una cultura economica
e materiale tale per cui l'ambiente
viene visto un po come una borsa da cui
attingere eternamente senza preoccuparsi
di dare qualcosa indietro perché abbiamo
completamente perse smarrito per strada
questa relazione personale ed è oggi più
che mai fondamentale fare tutto il
possibile
ristabilirla questa relazione e come
possiamo fare non è che sia la cosa più
facile del mondo perché l'ambiente allo
stesso tempo la cosa più universale che
unisce tutti ma anche più relativa che
esista poiché è molto diverso parlare di
ambiente qui in russia dove registro
questo video o farlo in nord africa o in
cina o in india bisogna andare per gradi
partiamo dalle parole la lingua che
secondo me descrive il concetto di
ambiente nel migliore dei modi e la
lingua tedesca in tedesco ambiente si
dice un bel cioè il mondo belt che sta
intorno a noi un bel the queen di questo
già ci aiuta a capire che l'ambiente non
è solamente costituito dalle foreste e
deserti le montagne gli oceani cose che
la maggior parte di noi non vedrà mai
nel corso della propria vita ma è
essenzialmente ciò che inizia quando
finiscono i confini della nostra persona
fisica quindi il mondo intorno a noi le
nostre case il nostro quartiere la
nostra città le colline intorno alla
nostra città
e l'ora per stabilire questa relazione
tanto per cominciare dobbiamo fare
quello che faremmo con un qualunque
soggetto del nostro ambiente cioè
frequentarlo fare delle passeggiate
nella natura nei boschi in montagna
uscire guardare l'ambiente che ci
circonda
piantare un albero con le nostre mani
non pagando una persona con la faccia
per noi ma proprio scavare una buca con
le nostre mani sporcarsi le ditte di
terra e inserire fisicamente un albero
nel suolo di modo che possiamo
percepirlo realmente come parte di noi
come come un nostro figlio un membro
della nostra famiglia allargata e una
volta che iniziamo a comprendere questa
cosa che ci scatta qualcosina dentro
allora possiamo entrare in uno stato
mentale diverso riabituarci per esempio
esercitare quotidianamente come una
sorta di meditazione un senso di
gratitudine verso ciò che abbiamo verso
ciò che l'ambiente ci dona quanti di voi
si ricordano prima di mangiare qualcosa
che non è così scontato avere qualcosa
da mangiare che se lo possiamo ottenere
è perché siamo veramente molto fortunati
prendersi quei 30 secondi di tempo prima
di ogni pasto per ringraziare di avere
qualcosa da mangiare quando utilizziamo
un oggetto per il nostro lavoro che è
stato costruito con materie naturali
prendersi un momento per dire grazie
sono fortunato e rendersi conto che non
è tutto così scontato
allora questa cosa piano piano può
iniziare a trasformarci come persone e
il passo successivo e quindi fare
qualcosa di concreto per esempio
supportare le onlus e le organizzazioni
progetti le aziende che hanno al loro
centro al centro della loro attenzione
lo sviluppo di idee progetti
assolutamente eco sostenibili
naturalmente non è facile trovarli in un
mondo dove il greenwashing diventa una
pratica disgraziatamente sempre più
diffusa ma utilizzando con
consapevolezza e gli strumenti che
abbiamo nella nostra epoca possiamo
trovare un sacco di influencer
divulgatori personaggi pubblici che
spendono interamente la loro vita alla
ricerca di questi progetti all'indagine
di tutto ciò che va in una certa
direzione per aiutare più persone
possibile a veicolare le proprie risorse
verso un determinato tipo di visione del
mondo e a questo punto il passo ancora
successivo è coinvolgere se stessi in
prima persona cioè cambiare le proprie
abitudini in base alle proprie
possibilità
il che vuol dire fare il possibile per
rifornirsi di energia da produttori di
energia verde chi lo può fare rendere la
propria abitazione autonoma da un punto
di vista energetico fare il possibile
per evitare di utilizzare mezzi di
trasporto ad alto inquinamento come per
esempio l'aereo e io da questo punto di
vista sono sicuramente il primo della
lista a dover fare un esame di coscienza
poiché il mio lavoro di viaggiatore mi
impone di spostarmi molto spesso
tuttavia da quando ho deciso di pensarci
seriamente faccio il possibile per
ridurre al minimo indispensabile questi
spostamenti
oppure ancora qualche anno fa ho scelto
di dedicare una buona parte delle mie
energie lavorative a restituire ciò che
io della natura dell'ambiente prendevo
per il mio lavoro ed è così che è nato
se va project questo progetto costruito
con alcuni amici dove dedichiamo del
nostro tempo per fare documentari che
vendiamo per finanziare un progetto di
riforestazione ad oggi abbiamo piantato
quasi 8 mila alberi e mi piace pensare
che sia un modo di restituire almeno
parzialmente alla natura tutto ciò che
lei mi ha dato nel corso della mia vita
poi andando ancora di più nel quotidiano
di ciascuno di noi
ridurre il più possibile o meglio
eliminare completamente il consumo di
carne pesce e prodotti di derivazione
animale perché ormai il consenso
scientifico è unanime su tutti i campi
sia dal punto di vista medico
nutrizionale che dal punto di vista di
consumo di risorse emissioni di gas
serra
eccetera eccetera sono prodotti di cui
non abbiamo bisogno a cui tutti noi
possiamo rinunciare senza cambiare
minimamente il nostro stile di vita e
che sono realmente un serio problema per
il nostro pianeta ad ogni modo dobbiamo
tutti quanti tenere bene a mente che
tutti questi gesti tutte queste azioni
sono semplicemente degli strumenti da
mettere al servizio di un qualcosa di
più grande ed è in questo qualcosa di
più grande che si giocherà la grande
partita del cambiamento che tutti noi
stiamo sperando di vedere non mi
riferisco naturalmente a una grande
volontà politica condivisa perché non è
certo con il green deal dell'unione
europea con la svolta ambientalista
delle grandi potenze che risolveremo
tutti i problemi legati all'ambiente
naturalmente la politica farà il suo
lavoro ma disgraziatamente ci stiamo già
accorgendo che le principali potenze
mondiali stanno cercando di utilizzare
l'ambiente come uno strumento di
contrasto di conflitto lune contro le
altre quindi come uno strumento di
separazione e non come lo strumento di
unione come teoricamente dovrebbe essere
fino a partire dagli accordi di rio
passando per il protocollo di kyoto fino
agli accordi di parigi allora cosa può
essere questo qualcosa di più grande al
cui servizio mettere tutte le nostre
azioni e i nostri cambiamenti niente
altro che la forza più potente più
universale che unisce ogni singolo
essere umano e cioè l'amore che è quella
forza che fa sì che quando il nostro
amico si trova in difficoltà noi
facciamo di tutto per dargli una mano
dobbiamo far sì che l'ambiente diventi
un nostro amico che diventi una persona
cara che diventi un membro della nostra
famiglia e al momento non lo stiamo
facendo perché il più delle volte
percepiamo l'ambiente come una minaccia
lo percepiamo come un qualcosa che può
crearci dei problemi può crearci dei
fastidi e se siano completamente onesti
con noi stessi ci accorgiamo che è molto
più grande l'emozione che proviamo di
fronte alla paura di una qualche
calamità naturale rispetto alle emozioni
che proviamo nella gioia di vedere una
foresta crescere ecco io credo che la
partita si giochi esattamente su questo
confine qua se riusciremo a trasformare
le nostre esistenze da esistenze di
paura in esistenze di amore allora
realmente avremo ristabilito questa
connessione che abbiamo perso e che è la
cosa più importante da recuperare al
giorno d'oggi siamo nel 2021 in italia è
l'anno di dante sono 700 anni della sua
scomparsa e in uno dei suoi versi dante
ci ha regalato una grande verità da
questo punto di vista
ve lo ricorderete tutti no amor ch'a
nullo amato amar perdona quando metti
amore nel circolo della vita non puoi
fare altro che riceverne altrettanti
indietro e allora nel momento in cui noi
saremo realmente sinceramente in grado
di provare reale amore verso ciò che ci
circonda verso gli alberi che stanno
intorno a me verso le foglie che da essi
sono cadute qualche settimana fa allora
tutto sarà più naturale più automatico
più spontaneo e io sono sicuro che
quando amore sarà l'energia esclusiva
che noi metteremo nell'ambiente
circostante nel nostro un bel allora in
cambio non potremo fare altro che
riceverne altrettanti grazie di avermi
ascoltato e buon proseguimento
[Musica]